and ironically ironically in 2020 for
the first time in in both franchises
history they're both oh and five so
there were ever a time for both of us to
take over the jets and giants it is now
uh where to begin with the jets though
can i can i tell can i can i begin here
please can i begin with my first move my
first move because i keep shaking my
head when this guy i i've had
adam gase on that list at least four or
five times in 23 shows right so he's
been on there like 20 of the time
already
i got to fire this guy this guy is gone
i don't understand
when people talk about adam gase like
bill belichick and said hey nobody is
nobody puts together a better game plan
than adam gates that's an actual quote
he said it last year
um this year
the jet ceo called him brilliant
what hey
adam gates if you look at the end of
miami his entire tenure with the jet
there's nothing brilliant about him the
only mystery to adam gates the only
thing that puzzles me
is like how he continues to have the job
he never should have gotten the job they
really came down it was mike mccarthy
and adam gates so he leaves a bad
situation gays i'm talking about
screws up miami
leaves a bad situation there and then is
the choice
the inspired choice of the jets nothing
has gone well for adam gates so he holds
into the job so first thing i'm doing
mike smith
is we co-gm this thing
adam gates has got to go
i don't know what you want to do with
the rest of the roster i don't know how
you feel about working we're going to
hold on to here let's start i'll get to
sam darnold in a second because i think
what we just thought about ryan tannen
here earlier i don't know how you can
make an accurate i know he's been
unavailable at times uh because of
injury i know he still had the turnover
problems in the lead that he's had at
usc
i don't know how you can make any kind
of determination on sam darnold
under these circumstances especially not
the kind of determination
that would prompt you to consider
i mean this hypothetical consider that
if they bottom out this year
and get a shot at a quarterback
trading the guy that you took third
overall
or that that organization shall we say
the organization took third overall um
and and going back at the quarterback
spot again i know i know the cardinals
just did it with josh rosen and it looks
like it was the right decision to you
know he was drafted tenth and then get
you know kyle murray what
we're talking about the new york jets oh
i mean they would like they would
totally do it no they would do something
like that
as they should
as they should look i okay can i answer
they should give up on sam darnold now
yes if they get if they get a shot at
trevor lawrence or justin fields
tank they should get
yeah come on man that's that's how you
end up and then they go ruin him and
then they'll ruin the next one just like
they run in this one no no
how's the guy gonna be worthy of the
third pick of the draft and even if
somebody else wouldn't take him third he
was a first pick maybe he was first
that was not
maybe he wasn't worried about sam
darnold what do you look like michael
vick anyway half the time running for
his life you know throwing touchdowns
across his body to braxton burials
you know i mean how are you gonna tell
me sam darnold's not good how do you
know i just gave you the speech i said
with ryan tannehill don't tell me you
know who's good and who's not good man
this is how i'll tell you this is how i
tell you that sam darnold's not good now
how would i give up on him because i
wasn't a fan of his usc
so he
had come out if he had come out a year
earlier his stock was higher the year
before his draft year so if he had come
out then
you know maybe it would have been
different he would have gone to a
different team uh been in a better
situation but
his his last year in college really
raised some red flags this whole
turnover thing this is this this this is
not an aberration this is who he is like
some guys are just like that some guys
get injured and that's who they are
they're just injury prone they can't
help they didn't do anything wrong
they're just injury prone he is a good
i'm not trying to excuse adam gates one
last time he looked at the jeff's roster
and look to be honest part of the reason
it looks like that is because whatever
talent they get they don't like to hold
on to it for whatever reason i mean see
jamal adams i mean it's like you know
they they i think there was a stat where
they had like five first rounds in a row
that never finished a rookie contract
something like that i don't have it in
front of me but it was some ridiculous
referendum
on this organization's inability to
retain whatever talent they happen to
fool around and look up and get okay so
um their their roster
is garbage like it is like the perfect
franchise mode roster and i would have i
would have gotten rid of le'veon bell a
long time ago here's another jets joke
yeah
just bring him in
that's the that's the first jeff's joke
the just joke is that you pay a running
back that kind of money that's that's
part one of the jets joke okay
part two of the jets joke
is that you don't use him properly that
you don't the the guy who's as versatile
running back as anybody in the league
when he did play in pittsburgh that you
don't get him more involved in the
passing game that he that he ends up
playing 18 games and getting 27 million
dollars out of you
that he doesn't have a hundred yard game
that you completely misuse him so much
so that he is passively aggressive
passive aggressively excuse me liking
tweets talking about his misuse on
twitter that's the second part of the
joke you know what the third part of the
joke is here's the third part i left my
i left the jets are trying to trade
le'veon bell like oh okay so you're
looking for some other team to be just
as stupid as you are and give you value
in return for that contract and a player
at a position that everybody knows
you're gonna get rid of so okay
though so
i would have definitely dropped i would
have definitely cut le'veon bell and
giving the ball to michael p ryan and
found a running back the way everybody
else does but what would you about to
say all right so no no so let me get
this straight so you in in your
franchise mode with the jets
you're holding on to sam darnold because
i'm i'm building around sam i'm i'm i'm
yes i'm standing with sam daryl i'm not
spending another high pick on a
quarterback again no
no damn because i like the guy he's
coming out but
here's the other thing you did and i i
don't agree with the trade they should
have held on to jamal adams they were
all over the place they seemed like they
were going to prop they were promising
him that he was going to get a new
contract nicely they set up nice they
flipped so they got they they've got
multiple picks from someone seeing that
gave up quite a bit
for jamal adams
so
just because somebody else screwed up
and took sam darnold number three
overall i'm moving on i'm moving on from
sam darnold
and i'm moving on
from adam gase
um
i'm gonna need a little bit of time
i know i never believe it when teams
when people say about teams they have no
talent you're all drafting from the same
pool uh you're all going to the same
combine all scouts are relatively
talented like so it's not like the the
talent of the best team in the league
seattle is way up here and the jets are
way down there and they got no talent i
don't believe that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports